you know the fermi paradox
if they're common where the hell are
they you know
notwithstanding the various ufo reports
in roswell and all that they just don't
meet the bar
they don't clear the bar of scientific
scientific evidence in my opinion okay
so you know there's there's no clear
evidence that they've ever visited
us on earth here so and you know seti
has been now
the search for extraterrestrial
intelligence has been scanning the skies
and
true we've only looked a couple hundred
light years out and that's a tiny
fraction of the whole galaxy
a tiny fraction of these hundred billion
plus stars
nevertheless you know if
if the if the galaxy were teaming with
life
especially intelligent life you'd expect
some of it to have been
far more advanced than ours okay there's
no special
nothing special about when the
industrial revolution started on earth
right
the chemical evolution of our galaxy was
such that billions of years ago
nuclear processing in stars had built up
clouds of gas after their explosion that
were rich enough and heavy elements to
have formed earth-like planets even
billions of years ago so there could be
civilizations that are billions of years
ahead of hours
and if you look at the exponential
growth of technology
among homo sapiens in the last couple of
hundred years and you just project that
forward
i mean there's no telling what they
could have achieved even in
1 000 or 10 000 years let alone a
million or 10 million or a billion years
and if they reach this capability of
interstellar travel and colonization
then you can show that within 10 million
years or certainly a hundred million
years
you can populate the whole galaxy all
right
and they you know so then you don't have
to have tried to detect them beyond a
hundred or a thousand light years they
would already be here
do you think as a thought experiment do
you think it
it's possible that they are already here
but we humans are so human-centric
that we're just not like our conception
of what intelligent life
looks like yeah is is um
we don't want to acknowledge it like
what what if trees right
right right yeah but like okay i guess
the in the form of a question do you
think we'll actually detect
intelligent life if it came to visit us
yeah i mean it's like you know
you're an ant crawling around on a
sidewalk somewhere and do you notice the
humans wandering around exactly
and the empire state building and you
know rocket ships
flying to the moon and all that kind of
stuff right it's conceivable
that um we haven't detected it and that
we're so primitive compared to them that
we're just not able to do so
like if you look at dark energy maybe
yeah maybe we call it as a field
it's just that my own feeling is that in
science now
through observations and experiments
we've measured so many things
and basically we understand
a lot of stuff okay fabric reality yeah
the fabric of reality we understand
quite well and there are a few little
things like dark matter and dark energy
that
may be some sign of some super
intelligence but i
doubt it okay you know why would some
superintelligence be holding clusters of
galaxies together
why would they be responsible for
accelerating the expansion of the
universe so
the point is is that through science and
applied science and engineering we
understand so much
now that i'm not saying we know
everything but but we know a hell of a
lot okay
and so there's it's not like there are
lots of mysteries flying around there
that are completely
outside our level of um
of of exploration or understanding
yeah you know from i would say
from from uh the mystery perspective it
seems like
the mystery of our own like cognition
and consciousness
is much grander than like the degrees of
freedom of possible explanations of what
the heck is going on is much greater
there than in the
in the physics exactly how the brain
works
how did life arise yeah that's
big big questions but they to me don't
indicate
uh the existence of of of an alien or
something i mean unless we are the
aliens you know
we could have been contamination from
some rocket ship that
that hit here a long long time ago and
all evidence of it has been destroyed
but again
that alien would have started out
somewhere they're not
they're not here watching us right now
right
they're not among us
you